it's already infected your favorite game
and there's nothing you can do about it
it's something that you'll see people
constantly complaining about online but
many don't know what it is or how
challenging it can be if your game gets
new characters items cards or weapons on
a regular basis you've almost certainly
experienced its influence power creep
what the hell is this infuriating
[__] and where did it come from
well when new content is added to a game
to keep the experience feeling fresh it
most likely has to be stronger and more
exciting than what came before it and as
a result these innovations often raise
the base power level of the whole game
eventually rendering older content
pointless or redundant but it isn't a
new concept in fact it seems power creep
was first unleashed by tabletop RPGs
like Dungeons & Dragons
why are you casting magic missle there's
nothing to attack here in D&D power
creep was caused by the introduction of
new source books which added abilities
items and classes that made old ones
practically useless [__] I can feel my
neck beard coming in thicker as I talk
about this [__] in time power creep
crept its way into the next nerdiest
thing you can think of trading card
games magic the gatherings designers
started talking about the term around
2003 further explaining it to fans in
2004 the team making the cards were
trying to ensure that every set they
printed wasn't going to completely
negate their players entire collection
because of that started happening the
game would become too top-heavy and
collapse so they introduced restricted
card formats to contain the creep right
about now you're probably wondering so
what if it gets out of control
aren't stronger things better for a game
and yeah that's true but things are a
little more nuanced than that in today's
ultra competitive market most games that
want to stay relevant need a constant
flow of additional content just look at
how epic has maintained the fortnight
craze by updating the game nearly every
week I hate so much about the things
that you choose to be the challenge for
game developers with limited time is
that designing new and unique content
without invalidating older stuff is hard
so they usually end up introducing
characters that are stronger than the
rest expansions with loot that
outclasses the base games or insanely
broken cards and this causes the
baseline of power in your game to go up
forcing you to either embrace the new
content or be destroyed by it don't kill
this please that was an error now this
doesn't just apply to games where you
have to buy the new content even when
it's totally free if it's still
significantly stronger that can
invalidate all the time you put into a
character that got power creep out of
relevance and the worst part about power
creep is that once it starts it can't be
stopped
designers are stuck because their next
additions to the game have to be even
stronger otherwise what's the point
League of Legends has been dealing with
power creep for the better part of a
decade with the game's earliest waves of
Champions having very simple
one-dimensional kits whether they were
specialists in crowd control damage or
boring players to tears but the same
can't be said for modern champions riot
has learned a lot about character design
over the years and newer ones are much
more complex than their simpler
ancestors just look at Blitzcrank and
Thresh for example Thresh has a hook
passively gains permanent armor shields
and pulls allies towards him pushes
pulls and slows enemies and can even
reverse his hook to dive them while
Blitzcrank until recently had a hook a
knock up and a silence that was it to
reduce the gap between these generations
of champions riot has taken to reworking
older ones over the years this ensures
that they don't become completely
obsolete and it's been largely effective
while leagues far from perfect when it
comes to power creep it's in a pretty
good place compared to hearthstone
blizzards digital card game has been
suffering from it since the release of
its first expansion in 2014
hard Stone's history is rife with power
creep but the best example of it might
be piloted shredder a card that was four
three four four capable of summoning a
random to coast minion upon its death
what does that mean for non hearts
donors it basically meant that on top of
having pretty aggressive stats piloted
shredder would get six Manas worth of
minions for the cost of four and while a
pop shredder could set you on the path
to victory other times it could be the
cause of your downfall never trade guys
thank you so much for watching if you
enjoy joy what
[__] that [__]
however that small chance of getting
[__] didn't matter piloted shredder
was so powerful than it totally warped
hearthstone
all of a sudden every player had to look
at their deck and ask if that 4 mana
card was worth playing over piloted
shredder Blizzard tried a few things to
balance out the shredder nightmare they
printed worse 2 drops so that the pool
of random creatures that the shredder
could summon got weaker but they also
printed cards with better stats so they
could attack the shredder and actually
survive it didn't work but more
importantly it completely changed the
game if a card wasn't better than
shredder it wasn't worth playing and
sure Blizzard could have nerfed shredder
like they did with other cards but it
was far from the only overpowered card
in that set eventually they were forced
to create an entire format for older
powerful cards like piloted shredder so
they could go back to printing newer
ones that didn't have to answer it
splitting up formats like hearthstone
and magic do or rejigging older
characters like League overwatch and
dota are viable ways of mitigating power
creep but they aren't the only solutions
some developers have chosen to look at
the challenge in a different light I
would say like two years ago I would
have said no no no no we want to have
like more depth to every operator and we
feel like the original one our big light
on the suspect and the more time goes
and don't know we experiment I think
there is place for both of those
operators so if we were to come back and
he walk every original operator that I
hope that we are going to do at some
point in the future I think we won't
have everyone become a super we
specifically I think we will still keep
some like super psycho on Ubisoft likes
the fact that their base operators are
simple and often outclassed by their
more complex DLC counterparts now not
everyone in the siege community agrees
with Ubisoft's philosophy for some the
nonstop power creep of new operators and
their gadgets is only creating problems
for the game siege does have a few
examples of operators that got power
creeped out of relevance buck does
everything sledge does
but from range and the existence of
characters like maverick and Mira has
reshaped the way the game is played and
let's cut the crap
we know that maestro is just a more
viable chef boyardee tachanka look no
matter how you slice it power creep is
an unstoppable force the developers have
to combat everyday keeping a game fresh
without destroying its foundation is a
delicate balance and while there's
really no permanent fix or way of
avoiding it once its introduced all we
can hope is that the power creep can be
contained and doesn't suck the life out
of the games we love now some of you
have been wondering about Josh and let
me tell you he's fine
I just power creeped him out of what is
so he's currently being reworked and
today I can happily show you what Josh
2.0 is gonna look like we've given him
robot eyes with laser vision one
mechanical arm with the strength of a
thousand arms and of course a digital
brain preloaded with every meme known to
man smoggy today I can happily show you
what Josh 2.0 is gonna look like see if
I don't have to say fact it's easy I
just talk nonsense man
as soon as you make it factual and
informational unfucked
yes
[Music]